Debra Katz is the attorney representing
Christine Blasi Ford good morning good
morning Debra let me ask you this would
your client be willing to testify under
oath in front of the full Senate
Judiciary Committee my client will do
whatever is necessary to make sure that
the Senate Judiciary Committee has the
full story and the full set of
allegations to allow them to make a
fully informed decision but testifying
in public under oath in front of the
Senate Judiciary Committee with the
American people watching that's an
enormous amount of pressure is she
willing to go that far
she's willing to do what she needs to do
she is willing to hopefully tell her
story in a manner that is a fair
proceeding unfortunately what we're
already hearing this morning is that the
DEM that the Republicans intend to play
hardball they intend to grill her this
is not an exercise that is designed to
get at the truth this is an exercise
that's designed to terrify somebody
who's already been traumatized why does
your client believe that Judge
Cavanaugh's alleged behavior in high
school disqualifies him from becoming a
Supreme Court justice she hasn't taken
that position she came forward to tell
her representatives about a very
traumatic event that occurred to her
that the nominee committed she believes
it bears on his character but she has
not taken a position that he should not
be confirmed you say that the
Republicans are going to try to grill
your client explain your sense then of
we're in this complicated place right
now and with this particular story where
when allegations are made it's very
important for everybody to take those
quite seriously on the other hand there
is an inquiry process that has to take
place to find out what the truth of
things are but in asking questions it
can sound like grilling so how does one
find the balance there between asking
probing questions and not seeming like
you're doubting the accuser or doubting
anybody's ability to come forward with
an accusation
I think intention matters I think if we
are trying to reel
engage in an inquiry to get it the truth
a highly politicized environment such as
the one we're in is not designed to do
that
Deborah there's been criticism from both
Republicans and even some Democrats
about how Dianne Feinstein handled this
letter in this allegation the letter was
dated July 30th and your client wrote as
a constituent I expect that you will
maintain this as confidential until we
have further opportunity to speak did
your clients speak with Dianne Feinstein
and is she satisfied with how she
handled this allegation
she's very satisfied with how Dianne
Feinstein handled this allegation she
did come forward and with this letter
she said on July 30th that she did have
a conversation with the senator who made
it clear that she thought that these
allegations were important and that they
were serious and her staff checked in
with us routinely Deborah can I ask you
your client has alleged that Kavanaugh
and the other boy at the party
were quote stumbling drunk was your
client also drinking my client would had
a beer she was not stumbling drunk
the men were stumbling drunk and one
only needs to look at the writings of
Mark judge who was the other person
present no to know that he wrote about
his stumbling drunk he and other members
of Georgetown Prep were repeatedly
routinely this was part of their culture
and I know Deborah that that she has
accounts from her husband and from her
therapist in around 2012 to corroborate
her story did she tell anyone about what
happened though at the time of the
incident she did not and like many
trauma victims especially young trauma
victims they try to put it away
and try to go forward with their lives
and really try in their own heads to
minimize it
unfortunately this issue continued to
come up and be extremely problematic in
her adult life affecting her
relationship with her husband and that's
the context in which this came up which
was in couples therapy where she
disclosed this very traumatic event that
she had tried for decades to try to
minimize in her own life but it was an
event that was so traumatizing she
continued to have
the anxiety and the aftermath effects
that really have defined her life in a
significant way
Deborah Katz thank you so much for
joining us this morning thank you for
having him we should also note that Mark
judge has not responded to our request
for a comment he told the New York Times
on Friday quote I never saw anything
like what was described